[Musique]
je trouve votre sentiment sur les
mouvements concernant la manifestation
contre la retraite quand il ya autant de
travail qui a autant de chômeurs autant
de gens qui sont dans la logique comme
on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
qu'est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à
repenser le travail c'est vraiment une
question philosophique pour moi je
défends les gilets jaunes qui sont pour
moi les les sous prolétaires je défends
également ces gens là qui pour le coup
ce sont les prolétaires mais qui sont
organisées pourquoi est-ce que c'est
toujours les mêmes qui payent les pots
plus modestes et c est pourquoi ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui échappent soit à
l'impôt soit aux ponctions d'autres
choses qui font que s'il y avait
vraiment un désir de d'équité les
français seraient probablement plus à
même de devenir qu'il consente à ce
traitement est ce que vous avez compris
quelle était la revendication au moment
des gilets jaunes tout au départ ce sont
juste des gens qui disent si vous
augmentez le prix du carburant nous on
va pas pouvoir des gens disaient mais
moi je suis chez mes parents parce que
je ne peux pas me payer un loyer alors
que je travaille donc dès le départ
c'était une revendication de dignité
mais vous avez dit on n'a pas écouté ces
gens là comment vouliez vous les écoutez
puisque personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre y en a un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale
[Musique]
nouvelle intervention du premier
ministre pour faire le point sur la
crise du coroner et russes en france un
dispositif et des mesures étaient
attendues pour le déconfinement
progressif annoncé par emmanuel macron
le 11 mai prochain mais il n'y a pas eu
d'annoncé ce soir à part un droit de
visite à partir de demain dans les ehpad
alors que le bilan enfants s'approchent
les 20000 morts on apprend que le second
tour plaidé pour vale sera sûrement
organisée après l'été déclarations de
jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
avec confinement prudent en europe qui
comptabilise les deux tiers des décès
dans le monde
quelques pays l'ont déjà entamé comme
l'autriche ou le danemark l'allemagne a
jugé la pandémie sous contrôle grâce
notamment à un large recours aux tests
et une semaine après les catholiques et
les protestants c'est le monde orthodoxe
télé
les fêtes de la pâque dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles bien sûr
aux etats unis près de 1900 mort de
pouce en 24 heures ce qui porte le bilan
à plus de 38 décès le président
américain qui a de nouveau mis en garde
la chine contre je cite d'éventuels
procès
si elle était sciemment responsable de
l'épidémie do not from qui encourage
toujours les américains à libérer
certains états du confinement pour
relancer l'économie dans les états qui
votent traditionnellement démocrate
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir ce nouveau point
presse d'edouard philippe du directeur
de la santé et de son ministre de la
santé aujourd'hui après l'annonce d'un
déconfinement le 11 mai par emmanuel
macron lundi dernier les français
attendent et long à dire les précisions
sur les modalités de la sortie
progressive du déconfinement alors
qu'ils entament leur deuxième mois chez
eux une feuille de route est toujours en
préparation a déclaré le premier
ministre elle sera dévoilée dans les
quinze jours prochains pas de réponse
concrète donc ce soir edouard philippe a
simplement inverti les français il va
falloir adopter de nouvelles habitudes
le quotidien sera différent et on va
prendre tout de suite la direction de
matignon pour rejoindre notre reporter
nadège abderrazak bonsoir nadège vous
avez suivi cette longue conférence de
presse que faut-il en retenir
écoutez un magali il faudra vivre avec
le virus at il dit pas de vaccin avant
2021 pas de traitement efficace ou
connue même si la recherche se poursuit
le premier ministre s'est montré
réaliste six jours après la dernière
allocution du président de la république
il prévient la prévention sera
déterminante dans la politique de
déconfinement le premier ministre a
indiqué qu'il faudra continuer à vivre
avec le respect des gestes barrières
qu'il faudra tester tous ceux qui
présentent des symptômes ou qui ont été
en contact avec des personnes malades
qu'il faudra également isolé elle est
porteur de virus vous propose d'écouter
edwards s'est dit c'est que beaucoup de
ceux qui nous regardent aimerait que
j'entre dans le détail de ce qui va se
passer
le 11 mai et dans les jours les semaines
et les mois qui suivront
je ne répondrai pas à toutes ces
questions aujourd'hui je le ferai
bientôt dans les quinze jours qui
viennent lorsque je présenterai le plan
que le président de la république m'a
demandé de préparer
il est en train d'être travaillé dans
tous ses détails et nous serons au
rendez vous la question des masques a
aussi a été évoquée aujourd'hui pas de
problème de pénurie selon le premier
ministre un qui annonce que 8 millions
de masques sont produits chaque semaine
en france contre 4 millions à début
janvier le port du masque sera
obligatoire devrait être obligatoire
dans les transports en commun le premier
monstre s'est aussi exprimé sur
l'importance de la réouverture des
écoles à partir du 11 mai on écoute les
écoles n'ouvriront pas partout le 11 mai
et ne fonctionnera pas un partout le 11
mai dans les conditions dans lesquelles
elle fonctionnait le 11 février
mais nous devons commencer à ouvrir les
écoles pour une raison très simple
aujourd'hui beaucoup de professeurs font
un travail remarquable
ils font en sorte que le lien entre
l'élève et le professeur qui évidemment
d'une nature très différente en période
de confinement et parfois d'une nature
un peu insatisfaisante
soit maintenu que le travail
d'acquisition de réflexion j'allais dire
d'élévation même des élèves puissent se
poursuivre mais un certain nombre
d'élèves n'ont pas accès à ces
instruments se retrouve dans une
situation où le lien avec l'école est
rompu
cette situation est une situation qui
présente pour la nation c'est un grave
danger les enfants
c'est ce que nous disent les
scientifiques ne semble rien craindre
pour eux mêmes car l'immense majorité de
la quasi exclusivité des enfants sont
atteints par des formes bénignes voix
totalement asymptomatiques de la maladie
une crise sanitaire sans précédent qui
va se poursuivre qui va entraîner crise
économique qui ne fait que commencer
elle sera brutal prévient le premier
ministre la france connaîtra en 2020
sapir la plus forte récession depuis
1945 la croissance sera négatif à -1 8%
les cafés restaurants et théâtre et
cinéma ne réouvriront pas à leurs portes
au 11 mai par ce qui est bien il n'est
pas possible de limiter la propagation
du virus dans ces lieux déclare edouard
philippe l'exécutif qui prépare donc là
près confinement pour le 11 mai une date
qui n'assure pas pour autant la fin de
l'épidémie à une épidémie qui a fait
près de vingt mille morts
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions nadège abderrazak en direct
de matignon à paris et on continue de
parler de cette conférence de presse
avec esther benbassa sénatrice europe
ecologie les verts de paris membre de la
commission des lois
bonsoir esther benbassa bonsoir elle
avec mou sur rt france qu'en avez vous
retenu de cette longue conférence de
presse qui a duré près de deux heures on
attendait certaines modalités de
déconfinement il y en a eu selon vous
c'était une allocution très longue moi
je m'attendais à ce qu'il y ait un peu
plus de d'éléments est là on a on a
entendu ce qu'on connaissait déjà
on n'a rien sur
le déconfinement enfin la période qui
suivra le déconfinement vaguement on a
parlé des écoles et qu'il faudrait
ouvrir comme les suivants monsieur blanc
caire a dit la même chose déjà tous les
tests on est toujours un peu dans le
vague
on produit des tests
oui ils étaient 150 mille un test par
semaine et à partir du 11 mai cinq cent
mille je veux bien ce retrait est très
profitable pour nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens parce que là ils ne sont pas
le dépistage n'est pas très très active
et la même chose pour les mars que j'ai
été étonné on parle des masques on
produit on ne trouve pas un seul masque
dans le commerce mais je ne sais pas
comment nous allons avoir des masques
des à partir du 11 mai pour prendre les
transports en commun mais rien n'est
clair c'était un discours d'eau tiède et
une sorte de dison de défense du
confinement le le premier ministre
venait sans arrêt vous nous dire
pourquoi ce confinement avait été
bénéfique et que ça avait fait baisser
le nombre d'entrées dans les hôpitaux
il a martelé cela à plusieurs reprises
et je suis étonné qu'il y ait si peu
vraiment d'informations supplémentaires
puis liste hurlait le télétravail il n'a
pas été très clair et puis les
entreprises qui le peuvent
vous savez on veut avoir des éléments
précis on n'écoute plus de deux heures
quasiment et on écoute notre premier
ministre et il est toujours vague et
nous sommes toujours inquiets ce n'est
pas un hasard s'il ya que 46% des
français et qui font confiance au
gouvernement
alors on a eu un long exposé également
sur ce que l'on sait ce que l'on ne sait
pas sur ce virus est ce que
on a des anticorps ou pas après avoir
contracté la maladie
ce genre de choses finalement c'est
aussi le l'inconnu qui fait qu' on ne
sait pas vraiment comment sortir de ce
confinement selon vous il ya bien sûr
l'inconnu il ya aussi les informations
scientifiques parfois disons
contradictoires c'est vrai aussi mais un
premier ministe de braid plus rassurant
et être plus clair plus net et ne pas me
brouiller l'esprit avec des chiffres
qu'on voit tous les soirs d'ailleurs et
des graphiques qui ne nous font pas
avancer et nous sommes toujours dans le
flou franchement et pourquoi une
allocution si longue
c'est ce et de la communication c'est
quasiment lunaire de voir que et on
n'avance pas on n'avance pas et c'est ça
qui m'inquiète comme politique parce que
je revais oui excusez moi je voudrais
savoir qu'est ce qu'on fera après le
déconfinement on est toute la question
est de savoir si on peut être protégés
pour se dé confinement et en
l'occurrence il manque toujours des
masques des tests et oui des
respirateurs là il ya un peu plus de
lits dans les hôpitaux d'accord c'est
très bien ça c'est très bien mais en
faire on peut aussi à partir du 11 mai
entrait dans une phase de novo de pique
voilà bien sûr il a dit il nous a dit
qu'il faut bien sûr respecter les la
distanciation les gestes barrière donc
oui tout cela mais on le sait est vous
le voir devant les sans pluie dans les
pharmacies partout on lit cela c'est
très bien de le répéter mais alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est ne sais même pas si tous les
enfants suivront les cours au même
moment dans les mêmes salles dans
d'autres salles le matin une partie
l'après midi une autre partie est ce que
les enseignants et accepteront de
d'enseigner dans ces conditions peu
propices à la protection de leur vie
parce que les enfants ils n'ont pas et
n'ont pas de symptômes souvent mais ils
sont des vecteurs d'infection est est ce
que les enseignants auront les outils
nécessaires pour se protéger
on ne sait rien une belle grèce demain
en outre 8 1 une des pistes est sûre le
sur l'ouverture des établissements
scolaires c'est peut-être de prioriser
les élèves en zone difficile qui aurait
été déconnectés des des cours par ce
confinement
donc certains territoires entrerait à
l'école avant d'autres ça vous paraît
une bonne solution
j'ai été très très longtemps enseignante
je trouve cela un peu compliqué à
réaliser et un peu discriminatoire
que signifie des élèves en difficulté
comment on va les trier
comment on va le savoir est ce qu'on va
ouvrir les écoles seulement dans les
quartiers populaires quartiers
difficiles
voilà est-ce que les autres parents ne
seront pas compte en se disant oui mais
pourquoi mes enfants n'iront pas à
l'école non plus ce sont des questions
vraiment de nous sommes encore plus
inquiet quand on entend des allocutions
de ce genre on ne sent pas à rassurer
c'est ça qui est né qui pose problème à
mon avis il ya une seule bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on pourra visiter nos aînés et
bien sûr ce avec certaines barrières de
protection obligatoire ce qui est normal
et et mais à part cela
moi je n'ai pas appris grand chose et
ces barrières
effectivement pour ces personnes qui
iront voir les aînés dans les ehpad il
faudra aussi pouvoir leur fournir des
masques et des protections pour pouvoir
voir ses aînés oui pas seulement aux
personnels qui travaillent dans les
épaules mais aussi il faudrait des
masques et de dépistage va à paris on a
commencé lamelle a commencé le dépistage
dans les ehpad
ce qui est une très bonne chose
les personnes âgées qui sont dans les
ehpad même pas de masque et que nous on
n'a pas de masque non plus ce qui allons
visiter les aînés alors comment on va
faire c'est tout ça est un peu
déconnecté
voilà c'est ce que je pense vous pensez
du fait que l'autriche l'allemagne des
pays comme la pologne 6 1 ont commencé
le déconfinement avec des mesures
concrètes et que la france elle peine à
mettre en oeuvre un plan
qu'est ce que ça dit de ce pays écoutez
l'allemagne par exemple à gérer elle a
géré la situation d'une manière
exemplaire
oui parce que ils ont ils les allemands
ont pris les choses à temps ils se sont
elles se sont affairés pour faire le
nécessaire et on comprend qu aujourd'hui
il ya un déconfinement parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup moins de décès que chez nous
est la même chose en autriche
oui et puis l'allemagne par exemple avec
plus de lits que nous nous on a sept
mille lits dans les hôpitaux les
allemands ont 27000 donc maintenant ils
peuvent des conflits mais parce que il
avait les outils nécessaires pour
pourront essayer essayer d'endiguer
cette pandémie n'a pas la pl pologne je
ne connais pas la situation pologne les
polonais n'étant pas très excusez moi
mais dans la boîte très démocratique
ils ont pu faire valoir la raison
économique sur les raisons de santé mais
l'allemagne est un pays comme l'autriche
aussi voilà ils ont des conflits nés au
danemark aussi voilà parmi les mesures
envisagées en rien n'est certain pour
l'instant aller voir philippe a répété
qu'on pouvait imaginer des hypothèses d
une
un tracking par une application des
personnes contaminées ce sera étudié à
l'assemblée nationale le 28 avril puis
au sénat qu'en pensez-vous montant
créatrice je crois que ce sera un débat
le 28 à l'assemblée le 29 au sénat c'est
un débat on ne vote pas une application
de ce genre et qui pour être efficace
doit être appliquée par 80% minimum de
la population on sera bien loin de ce
chiffre
vu que c'est aussi une application
liberticide
on ne sait pas comment on va protéger
les données comment on va les détruire
et quand est ce qu'on va les détruire il
serait peut-être beaucoup plus utile un
vu le coup et l'énergie n'est que lequel
la préparation la mise en place de ce
genre d'application il serait mieux
d'investir plutôt dans les tests dans
les masques et dans les respirateurs et
ses traits ce serait très bien parce que
parce que vous savez cet humble c'est
quand même une application qui peut
devenir facilement liberticide et qui
par la suite
comme vous le savez tout ce qui a été
voté en période l'état d'urgence s'est
banalisé et est entré dans le droit
commun et je m'inquiète 6 était prouvé
que c'était efficace
je serai la première à dire oui à ce
genre d'application ce n'est pas le cas
surtout que en france il ya que soissons
17% et des françaises et des français et
qui ont un smartphone et que parmi les
aînés les seniors le taux est de 40
environ de 40 44 %
donc cette application ne pourra pas
être utilisée
pas tous toutes les françaises et les
français et c'est un c'est un problème
nous avons une fracture numérique dans
notre pays alors peut-être investissons
dans des outils beaucoup plus efficace
et le résultat sera meilleur parce que
le même si c'est volontaire
qu'est ce que c'est le consentement en
période de crise si les entreprises
demandent à leurs employés ouvriers et
de prendre cette application de la
mettre en marche pour pouvoir travailler
dans l'entreprise
est-ce que c'est du consentement et yola
la pression aussi la pression de
l'opinion
si tu n'as pas l'application c'est que
tu n'aimes pas ton prochain alors est
donc là le la volonté dans ce genre de
de doughty est difficile à cerner voilà
en gros mais quelques divisions la
martre ce sujet on suivra ce débat merci
beaucoup esther benbassa d'avoir répondu
à nos questions sur rt france merci à
vous portez vous merci indé confinement
qui inquiète les agents du service
central du renseignement territoriale
ils craignent des violences sociales à
la sortie du confinement
la situation est déjà tendue la nuit
dernière des heurts ont éclaté notamment
à villeneuve la garenne dans les hauts
de seine après un accident de moto qui a
impliqué les forces de l'ordre selon une
source policière le conducteur de la
moto roulait à vive allure quand un
fonctionnaire à bord d'une voiture
banalisée a ouvert la porte de son
véhicule et l'a percuté le motard
souffre d'une fracture ouverte à la
jambe une tension dans les banlieues
plutôt prévisible c'est ce que dit farid
temsamani les porte parole de
l'association banlieues plus écoutez le
le confinement est vécue difficilement
danser dans ces territoires il faut le
dire très clairement pato forcément
respecter un peu à l'échelle du pays
mais
mais un peu plus dans ces quartiers là
parce que les logements sont parfois
très difficile à vivre lorsqu'on est
nombreux
les équipements numériques ne sont pas
forcément accessibles et donc du coup
tout ceci entraîne un confinement pas
toujours respectée et qui entraîne une
tension supplémentaire là l'économie
étant complètement arrêté n'ayant pas de
solution de repli
parfois pas forcément de chômage partiel
comme d'autres peuvent la voir ou de
télétravail
effectivement ça devient très très très
tendue je rappelle vraiment et je le
salue notamment les initiatives des
associations qui prennent le relais il
ya les gens qui à l'heure où je parle
n'ont pas de quoi manger dans leur
propre famille dans ces quartiers là la
situation est une véritablement assez
complexe est assez tendue à mon avis
en europe le bilan quotidien en espagne
baisse à 410 morts ces dernières 24
heures l'espagne qui est l'un des pays
les plus touchés par la crise sanitaire
il comptabilise 20 mille morts au total
le confinement qui est prolongée
jusqu'au 9 mai prochain c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le premier ministre pedro
sanchez hier avec un au passage une
bonne nouvelle pour les parents et pour
les enfants écoutent et partir de lundi
4 avril à partir du 27 avril le
gouvernement espagnol prendra des
mesures d'allègement pour l'aider
confinement si je puis dire de nos plus
jeunes enfants afin qu'ils puissent
sortir dans la rue et profiter au moins
aussi des améliorations comptable que
nous constatons dans l'évolution de la
pandémie mais les caches l abolition de
la peine elle l'europe qui amorce petit
à petit aussi le déconfinement dans
certains pays dès demain par exemple en
république tchèque enfants et étudiants
retrouvent
et de l'université en norvège ce sont
les crèches qui rouvrent leurs portes
en allemagne les magasins de petite
surface pourront également rouvrir des
mesures similaires déjà prises en début
de semaine par l'autriche par l'italie
ou encore par l'espagne l'union
européenne aura besoin de 500 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour se remettre
de cette crise au niveau économique
une somme qui viendrait s'ajouter à un
montant équivalent con il ya des jours
après des semaines de tractations ou de
l'europe
selon le président du mécanisme européen
de stabilité
c'est le fonds d'urgence de la zone euro
la manière la plus simple de réunir ses
500 milliards est de mobiliser la
commission européenne du budget de
l'union européenne
les dirigeants de l'ue aux qui doivent
se réunir par vidéo conférence le 23
avril et pour dany langues
économiste et maître de conférences à
l'université paris xiii il aurait fallu
le faire dès le début de la crise pour
soutenir justement financièrement ce
système de santé écoutez je vais aller
mettre cet argent sur la table en partie
avant et en particulier pour soutenir le
système de santé qui est et qui quand
même délabrée dans un certain nombre de
pays mais pour les autres secteurs ça ne
servait à rien ça sert à rien d'injecter
des liquidités dans l'économie
quand un certain nombre de secteurs sont
à l'arrêt et à mon avis il va falloir
faire un effort durable parce que là il
faut assurer le redémarrage dans
certains ont deux secteurs
il faudra surtout songer à ce que la
reprise soit durable et une reprise
durable
ça passe avant tout par la prise au
sérieux de la transition écologique
si on se retrouve dans cette situation
sanitaire délabré et désastreux c'est
aussi à cause de la mondialisation
libérale et al et aussi à cause du
délabrement du système de santé des
systèmes de santé dans qu'on a très
largement
donc il faut des sommes conséquentes
pour aller leur la transition écologique
il va falloir investir massivement pour
aller vers une relocalisation des
injures des industries donc tout ça
demande des milliards
et effectivement je ne suis pas certain
que 500 milliards suffiront
l épidémie qui progresse au royaume-uni
596 morts supplémentaires à l'hôpital
ces dernières 24 heures plus de 16 mille
décès au total et au delà de 120 mille
cas de contamination confirmés en tout
cas officiellement avec une inquiétude
importantes notamment dans les maisons
de retraite comme en france d'ailleurs
où certains redoutent un bilan bien plus
lourd mais dit et ce qui fit des
centaines de décès supplémentaires
constatés toutes les 24 heures déjà très
lourd le bilan humain annoncé par les
autorités britanniques ne prend en
compte que les décès à l'hôpital sans
comptabiliser ceux des établissements
pour personnes âgées
certains responsables du secteur déplore
cette situation nous avons plusieurs
résidants dans 10 de nos quinze maisons
de retraite qui ont des symptômes
ressemblant à des symptômes du kobe 19
le problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
accès à des dépistages pour eux
commençons à peine à obtenir des
dépistages pour notre personnel soignant
dans les maisons de retraite mais c'est
loin d'être le cas pour les résidents
selon karine glande un organisme qui
représente les maisons de retraite
indépendante près de 7500 personnes
seraient mortes dans ces résidences pour
seniors
bien loin des 217 dénombrés par le
bureau des statistiques nationales
à l'heure actuelle les maisons de
retraite sont en première ligne pendant
de nombreuses années notre secteur a été
négligée mais à présent nous sommes en
première ligne dans la lutte contre le
kobe 19
il nous avons besoin de plus de soutien
de la part du gouvernement
certaines personnes âgées parviennent
néanmoins combattre le kobe de 19 comme
cette patiente de 106 ans prise en
charge à birmingham après trois semaines
d'hospitalisation
vous vous souvenez ce matin nous
discutions
vous vous souvenez que je vous ai dit
que vous étiez la personne la plus âgée
à survivre à ce méchant virus qui
circule au oui selon public allthings
les autorités de santé locales 3084
maison de retraite en angleterre compter
des cas de coronavirus à la date du 15
avril
interrogé sur cet épineux dossier le
ministre britannique de la santé matin
de coqs reconnaît que le nombre réel de
morts est plus grand il assure qu'un
bilan officiel sera publié dans les
prochains jours aux états unis près de
1900 morts de plus en 24 heures ce qui
porte le bilan à plus de 38 décès le
président américain qui a de nouveau mis
en garde la chine contre je cite
d'éventuelles conséquences si elle était
sciemment responsable de l'épidémie
donald trump qui encourage également
vous voyez les américains à se libérer
ce sont ses mots à se libérer et
certaines se libérer de certains états
qui ont adopté le confinement il veut
relancer l'économie dans les états qui
votent traditionnellement démocrate
j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait eu beaucoup
de manifestations et je pense que
certains gouverneurs sont allés trop
loin
vous savez il y a beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont pas besoin qu'on leur dise quoi
faire ils ont vraiment fait tout ce que
nous leur avons demandé il ya quelques
états ou franchement j'ai parlé au
gouverneur et j'aurais pu leur dire quoi
faire si je l'avais voulu cela aurait
peut-être été politiquement correct des
wild web est correcte et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci beaucoup de votre
fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]